the main question that Davos leaders are
asking themselves is how can global
growth be restored in 2009 hmm how can a
little groove be restored in 2009 the
global crisis or generation is facing is
very profound and it is very very
dangerous and eat because it is going to
touch every aspect of our lives
according to people's view or at least
to youtube's pouring ways people feel
optimistic about the economy if people
perceived economy of being bad then the
economies and go bad the investors in a
time in their pockets the more
investments people don't I'm their
pockets no more spending you know
company or not gonna be hiring not
making any money or get any investments
one wellness economy be restored and
people have faith again this seems to be
our tiring theme throughout the people i
talked to and i believe i seed awareness
and fear for the year ahead has been
planted and in my opinion it will take
more than a year and a few changes on
the interest rate market to remove this
lack of confidence that has been
ingrained we should understand that
economy is cyclic meaning that the base
there are videos of growing videos of
the crazy with regards to the economy i
don't have any one solution i don't
think anybody has one solution there
will always be cause for debate with
regards to any solution whether maybe
this sheriff this year will be the year
that we actually bought them out in
which people like you government
officials and rescue leaders and work
with everyday Joe's like me Edith global
growth could be resumed in 2009 that
would be a miracle I believe modifying
the day 2 2010 would be more adequate
what we need are the proper tools
using the improper tools can leave this
recession into a depression and proper
tools such as increase in taxes
protectionist trade barriers and
contraction of the my supply